and that audiences as large as yours I
suppose some of your viewers were even
conceived in a parked car I'm not sure
I'm a professor of urban planning at
UCLA most of my research is on
transportation and land use and on
parking is a link between the two I'm
out to save the world one parking space
at a time
I think planning for parking in the
United States has been a disaster
American drivers parked free at the end
of 99 percent of their vehicle trips
just because the driver doesn't pay for
Parker doesn't pay the cost goes away if
the cost is still there it's not paid
for by the driver but if you pay for
Park me and every other role you have in
life as a taxpayer as a resident either
a tenant or a homeowner when you go
shopping when you go to the movies a
little bit of every transaction has a
small part shaved off to pay for your
parker one estimate of the total cost a
part of the free parking of the United
States is somewhere between what we pay
for Medicare every year and national
defense I think I've been lucky at
researching parking because it's escaped
other people's interest at least other
academics interest they think it's
either unimportant or trivial but I
think it is the single biggest land use
in any city and if it has a huge effect
on the way we live our lives well the
average car is parked 95% of the time so
what other transportation columnist were
chasing after the five percent of the
time the cars were moving I thought I
could find out what was happening during
the other ninety five percent of their
lives and said it audiences as large as
yours I suppose some of your viewers
were even conceived in a parked car
I recommend three basic reforms first is
get the right price for curb parking the
second is to make this politically
feasible by spending all of the meter
revenue to add public services on the
meter block so that people see they're
getting something for their money and
the third is to reduce all street
parking requirements what is the right
price for curb parking in order to make
the system work well you need about one
vacant space on every block so the
everybody driving around concede that
there's a vacant space wherever they
want to go nobody could say there's a
shortage of parking because every block
they go to there one or two vacant
spaces but the price has to be at the
level that will create that vacancy rate
so the key aspect of pricing reform is
is to get the prices right it'll be
different at different times of day you
know in different days of the week but
it should always be the lowest price the
city can charge and still have one or
two vacant spaces on every block well I
think that minimum parking requirements
have turned out to be a planning
disaster that the Dowell cities won't
allow anything to be built unless it has
ample free parking that drives up the
cost of all development just to reduce
the price of parking somebody has to pay
for that partner and if the city won't
allow these buildings to be built
without the parking the cities are
really driving us into it into a future
where almost everybody will drive
everywhere they go and park free when
they get there
if car parking is cheaper than all
street parking we all have to incentive
to hunt for current parking space we
drive around hoping to see a car leaving
but if you're hunting for parking a lot
of other people are too we studied the
effect of this in Westwood Village a
little shopping district next to UCLA
and cruised ourselves to find out how
long it takes to to find the space and
how far you have to drive it wasn't long
about three minutes
but if everybody does this over the
course of a year all this cruising for
under priced curb parking in Westwood
Village has about a million vehicle
miles a year that's four trips to the
moon or 36 trips around the earth in a
little 15 block shopping district the
cruisers don't pay much attention to the
bicyclists or pedestrian leads to
accidents people see an open space on
the other side of the street they'll
make a u-turn in the middle of the block
at least a dangerous behavior and
they're just doing what the city tells
them to do is to cruise for curb parking
because it'll save you money the city
sets the prices so they're inducing the
behavior and I think this is happening
all over the earth
Pasadena is a great example of what I'm
talking about it in terms of parking
policy it's one of those popular
shopping destinations in Southern
California now 30,000 people on a
weekend go to walk around but 30 years
ago it was a Skid Row with mostly vacant
stores the city wanted to put in parking
meters because of the all the curb
spaces were taken up by the employees of
the few shops who were there the person
said no way it will chase away the few
customers we have they argued for a
couple of years about this until the
city said alright if we put in the
meteors
we'll return all the revenue for added
public services and pasady there and
like that the verses said that's
different you didn't tell me that let's
run the meters to midnight let's run
them on Sunday let's charge a high price
so it was the revenue returned that
transformed the attitude towards paying
for parking
probably stores charging for parking and
the meter money is now over a million
dollars a year for a 15-block business
district about the same as Westwood
Village and they've replaced all the
sidewalks they cleaned up all the hours
they put all the wires underground they
steam clean the sidewalks twice a month
they sweep the sidewalks every night
they were was graffiti every night and
it's all paid for by meter by opacity to
pulled itself up by its parking meters
once the city began providing all these
enhanced public services all the
property owners began restoring their
buildings and it's a wonderful place to
go now made possible mainly not totally
but mainly by the revenue from the
parking meters and I think this could
happen in many downtown areas of many
cities